[Music]
[Laughter]
whoever thought mars would seem so
earth-like
every picture the rover perseverance
sends back of its rocky terrain and
climate
is more amazing than the last
it's easy to forget this is nasa's first
true astrobiological mission
searching for signs of life on another
planet
scientists are uncovering the mysteries
of the red planet
in real time they have confirmation of
entry interface
and when its secrets are revealed the
odds are good a canadian will have a
front row seat
like montreal native and current nasa
engineer farah alibay
or perhaps in the future toronto's
shamira andres
whose trajectory has taken her to the
european space agency
[Music]
along the way they're rewriting how we
perceive people in and around mission
control
alabay has become one of the new faces
of nasa as much for the complicated work
she does on the
semi-autonomous helicopter ingenuity as
the fearlessness she shows in her
personal life
her singular focus right now is on
ingenuity
which could arguably be one of nasa's
greatest achievements
programming a helicopter to fly
autonomously on another planet
is being likened to the wright brothers
first flight 117
years ago in kitty hawk north carolina
as a young girl she never imagined
herself
among the pioneers of space exploration
i didn't have that growing up i didn't
have someone who looked like me in this
position right i think i grew up in the
90s well like
sure there was a lot of interest in
space but a lot of people in these
positions were white men and and it took
a while for me to even
allow myself to dream that i could be
part of these people
fortunately she never gave up on her
dreams and while the mars rover
is named perseverance it has nothing on
alibay
who moved to england as a francophone
teenager before attending prestigious
cambridge university
when she struggled it made her work that
much harder
and when nasa didn't hire her at first
and then again
and again she always looked for another
door to open
it's not like the first nasa internship
i put in that they accepted
i probably had like 50 of them rejected
and one day someone
took interest at a dinner at a
conference
took interest in my research and offered
me an internship
[Music]
around the same time nasa's ingenuity
project was conceived in 2013
a young filipina canadian was imagining
her future
to be on a different more artistic stage
and shamira andres was singularly
focused on ballet
until a ride on a roller coaster changed
her life
it was a high school science project
ride the coaster and take measurements
but it lit a fire inside her to study
the mysteries of the universe
she ultimately chose to pursue science
but ballet was always tugging on her to
return
and now as a young graduate trainee with
the european space agency in the
netherlands
she likes the flexibility of having many
talents
for me i would really love to be a
dancing astronaut
if that is a profession that i can make
but for now i'm trying to find my
passion in planetary geophysics
and science communication and education
to that end she's also the president of
a group called
students for the exploration and
development of space
yes she likes to keep busy so she wants
to study ice on mars
figure out a way to become an astronaut
and inspire students to follow their own
path
in science space is contagious i think
so one once you've talked about space to
someone and you've got them hooked
it's kind of the hook that you need to
just get them interested and start
talking about it
canadians have a long history inspiring
space exploration
after the canadian government scrapped
the avro aero project in 1959
many of its engineers moved south to
contribute to the moon landing
in many respects not much has changed in
the last 60 years
for canadians to explore the universe
they first have to leave canada
we have the brains and a space agency
but there are limits to what is done
here we don't have
nasa we don't have the various nasa labs
but there's definitely you know there is
an ecosystem where canada excels
is in education mcgill professor ina
scharf's research into automation and
space debris
attracts international students but she
knows they'll take what they learn from
her
and go far and i think that's a great
thing that's a great thing
but i again i hope that they'll come
back eventually
i hope they'll start companies or come
and work for
for the companies that we have here for
every rule there's an exception
and eitan bulka is just that when he's
finished his phd at mcgill on increasing
the autonomy of unmanned aerial vehicles
the boston native hopes to find a job
right here
so i mean there's a lot of opportunities
here in montreal so i'm actually only
looking to stay
in montreal canada does have a large
aerospace sector that employs almost a
hundred thousand people
but statscan reports the vast majority
of our companies
93 export parts for planes
yet bulka sees opportunity so i think
when you get very specialized it in the
past it was
you know you kind of had to move to
california but now
a lot of these companies are are first
of all there are more in canada and in
montreal and they're more open
to having remote employees
borders it seems are for countries not
companies anymore
alibay went from montreal to england and
then back to north america
where she's found a home in california
and eventually i made it and i made it
where i wanted to be
mostly because this was my dream and so
every time someone told me no
every time i failed i was like well let
me just try again see if someone else
will let me
and andres may be working in holland
right now but she'll soon start her phd
in france
where she'll no doubt continue dancing
as precise as she
is she likes to point out there's no
linear path
to the stars for me right now i think
there are a lot of possibilities not
everything is impossible possible just
takes time right